hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
while president biden will make his
first primetime address this week
marking one year since the nation began
rolling out coronavirus restrictions
he has yet to hold a formal news
conference since taking office
host of media buzz and the media
buzzmeter podcast howie kurtz
weighs in on calls for the
commander-in-chief to do a back and
forth with reporters
and the relationship with the press and
the current and former president
texas governor greg abbott slamming the
biden administration
for what he calls a growing crisis at
the u.s mexico border
caused by a surge in migrant arrivals
gop congressman tony gonzalez of texas
shares his thoughts on president biden's
border policies and how he says the u.s
can improve its immigration system
plus commentary from fox news
contributor pastor robert jeffress
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm dana perrino i'm brian kilmeade i'm
shannon breme and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday march 10th 2021
i'm dave anthony president biden will
address the nation tomorrow night
but he still hasn't faced the media in a
full-length news conference
there is more to the presidency than
just reading off the teleprompter
and i hope i think it's our
responsibility to be aggressive
i don't think this press corps has given
joe biden a terribly hard time but to be
more aggressive
with every president and it's the
president's responsibility
to let reporters ask the questions that
they ask
i'm lisa brady after paying a visit to
the southern border
a texas congressman has a message they
have to understand
this isn't a challenge it is a crisis
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
if you count inauguration day this is
the 50th day
president biden has been in office and
he's facing mounting criticism for not
yet having
a big news conference to answer all
sorts of questions
on all sorts of topics by comparison
president trump had his after 28 days
34 for george w bush it only took
president obama
21 days back when joe biden was vp
tomorrow he'll address the nation after
the democratic-led congress approves the
nearly 2 trillion
coveted financial aid bill during his
first prime time address he'll talk
about kovid what we've
been through as a country and what the
path forward looks like and we'll focus
on
the next address once we get through
that white house press secretary
jensachi says a news conference will
happen by the end of the month
it's getting to be a pretty big deal now
i didn't expect nobody expected joe
biden to be anything like
donald trump when it came to dealing
with the press howie kurtz
is the host of media buzz on the fox
news channel the former president for
all of his contentious relationships
with the
arbiters of what he called fake news
talked to reporters several times a day
that was unusual
but i'm surprised that he that the
current president is only
taking a couple of questions at a time
maybe two or three times a week
and i think it's hard to avoid the
conclusion
it certainly helps with the white house
message discipline that his aides his
advisors his handlers
prefer this uh because if he does have a
lengthy discoveries which he will
soon inevitably but i don't think he's
going to have many of them that he might
go off script and he might commit a
gaffe and he might
step into a blunder and that would take
to him and the white house off message
they do have blunders and times where
he's gone off message
even during the presidential campaign to
fall back on as reasons to do that right
yeah and and look uh biden is not an
inspirational speaker
he i actually think he does fine with
the press uh
most of the time he has a good
substantive knowledge of government
having been around
for decades but you know dealing with
the media even when the media are being
obnoxious or hostile or rude or any of
the other
adjectives you might pick is part of the
job
uh he's not always going to just get to
do friendly chats with anderson cooper
and sit for interviews with his wife
for people magazine and i think that
there are a lot of missed opportunities
for president biden here
because you know i often use this phrase
you got to be able to show whether
you're a candidate
a governor or mayor or the president of
the united states that can hit major
league pitching
you stand up to tough questioning you
get your message out and you counter any
negative
aspects of coverage that are out there
maybe as biden grows more comfortable
maybe as we come out of the pandemic
he'll do it more
but i think he's always going to be more
reticent than certainly his predecessor
well the other day we had that kind of
odd moment where he was
talking with the house speaker and they
were talking about the covert relief
bill
so i want to thank you all i really mean
from the bot i want to thank you
thank you thank you thank you and i'm
happy to take questions if that's you
i'm supposed to do nance whatever you
want me to do
and then the feed gets cut i mean that
that looked really
odd yeah that was no accident uh because
obviously
you know in that instance maybe he was
more willing to take questions than
his staff had expected look there are
times we've all seen the videotape when
biden can get testy with reporters
he tends to be long-winded which um
is something the tendency that he's
battled for a long time
um but i do think you know he has a
responsibility
it's an accountability question to
regularly take questions
from the president we only allow two
questions you know you're getting kind
of like the quick pop of the day
and then he walks off and you don't get
uh topics that he might prefer not to
talk about such as the growing
migrant crisis at the border he
obviously wants to stay focused
on covet and the economy and look he's
giving a speech later this week
any president uh
enjoying the triumph of what's going to
be his first major legislative
accomplishment
especially with the spending of two
trillion dollars especially in the
middle of a pandemic
would be guilty of a political
malpractice if he didn't give a speech
but there is more to the presidency than
just reading off the teleprompter
and i hope i think it's our
responsibility to be aggressive
i don't think this press corps has given
joe biden a terribly hard time but to be
more aggressive
with every president and it's the
president's responsibility
to let reporters ask the questions that
they ask
sometimes a little grandstanding of
course on behalf of the public
you talked about earlier a hostile or
combative media
there was a lot of that of course with
the
trump press secretaries having their
time with the press
um have you seen that
with jen saki have you seen do you think
they're as
dogged as they had been in the prior
administration
asking questions there is simply no
question that gensake's press briefings
are more
civil that the temperature in the
briefing room has been lowered
compared to what sean spicer went
through compared to what uh sarah
huckabee sanders went through and most
recently
kaylee mcaddy um that's in part because
of the way she conducts herself
she says that blindness told her that
tone is very important so
she will push back and a couple times
she has you know kind of challenged the
premise of a question but she tries not
to make it personal
and of course she's not working for a
president who talks about the media or
some of the media as the enemy of the
american people at the same time i think
the press
broadly speaking agrees with a lot of
what biden is trying to do is broadly
supported
the covert relief bill for example uh
and some of the trump policies that he's
reversing
i do think there have been instances in
which the coverage has gotten more
critical
to me the most dramatic example of that
was when president biden failed to do
really much of anything
in response to releasing the report that
showed that
the crown prince of saudi arabia you
know had played the central role
in the killing of journalist jamal
khashoggi suddenly you had not only more
aggressive questioning but you had
liberal columnists you know denouncing
the president who had indicated he would
take a tougher line
towards saudi arabia so there are
exceptions but by and large this press
score is giving him an easier time he
also might still be
in the honeymoon phase um but as the
border
problems and you know unforeseen
problems around the world
would suggest and history would suggest
there's going to come a time when he's
going to hit some rough patches and then
i think
he might be a little more motivated to
get out there and do more interviews
because it's not just news conferences a
number of interviews
with both print and tv reporters
when he's a little bit more on the
defensive now we switch gears
there's a new fox nation special that
features howie kurtz and many others
remembering a conservative icon the
fourth branch of government
rush limbaugh with talent on loan from
god it's titled the age of rush about
the late
radio talk show host most people who
were conservative
did not have validation in the media for
their ideas
hollywood made fun of them still does in
movies
songs made fun of them musicians and so
forth here i come
and i simply validated what everybody
else
already felt it's narrated by former
vice president mike pence
one of many rush inspired to become a
talk show host
and then later a congressman a governor
and vp
his three-hour radio show was a
revelation for listeners
who'd never heard this type of radio
before it's a four-part series on fox
nation starting today
well it's very happy to be included
because i have covered raj and i've
talked
to rush a few times pretty much since he
became a national
figure uh with a radio show that became
just
uh transformed the media landscape so
what i think of first of all is this is
a guy who
essentially saved am radio who invented
the national
talk show format before rush limbaugh
there were talkers
uh opinionated people doing talk shows
but they were local there was somebody
in your town
rush limbo showed you could do it on a
national basis and well beyond that his
impact on the conservative movement
his uh influence among members of
congress and presidents he wasn't
originally a fan of george h.w
bush but after her sleepover at the
white house became more supportive
certainly his strong support
of donald trump um showed
the power of his words because when you
think about what rush limbaugh
accomplished it wasn't a tv show with a
lot of fancy graphics or a lot of
big-name guests
it was a got one guy sitting in the
microphone three hours a day
taking calls from the so-called ditto
heads and that i think
influenced not just the radio business i
think it influenced the cable news
business and
cable news on all the networks
eventually and especially in prime time
but also during they became a lot more
opinionated and i think that's part of
the legacy of rush
well obviously he was a big part uh gave
a lot of credit for the conservative
republican revolution in 1994 when the
gop took back the house
do you think that the fox news channel
would
have launched when it did if rush
limbaugh's show didn't exist
i think probably i do think he showed
that there was a hunger and
appetite a void for conservative
analysis and opinion
um and that's why his show in the more
than 600 stations and so forth became
so incredibly popular so i think it may
have at least provided a roadmap
for a more right-leaning national
network and now there's more than just
fox
to show that there was you know people
many people on the right felt that the
mainstream media didn't understand them
didn't get them didn't respect them
and we still have some of that today now
at the same time in what i've said and
written
about rush limbaugh i've had to point
out that he made mistakes
he had the addiction to painkillers he
at times insulted people with very
offensive language in one instance
he went after a student a young student
on the issue of birth control at
georgetown
law school and had to apologize so he
was
a polarizing figure a lightning rod that
was by design and the other thing that
limbaugh did is
early in his radio career he would not
just denounce the media he would go
after individual journalists by name now
that's very
commonplace today especially on places
like twitter but at the time
it was pretty unusual and again it spoke
to
a resentment a distrust of the media by
many conservatives that he tapped into
you were at the washington post for the
years his show was growing up and
becoming
the big juggernaut that it was what was
it like in the newsroom did people
listen did people pay attention to his
criticism
well this is the thing i mean since his
show was on in the middle of the day uh
most people weren't sitting in their
desk with radios they didn't listen it
wasn't like you could go online even
when there wasn't online
right away and find out what he had said
there was no transcripts
but you would always know a freshly gone
after you and he took a few acts at me
we had a sort of a uh
sometimes sparring and but definitely
respectful relationship
my voicemail would explode answering
service would explode with people
saying who didn't know me had never read
what i'd written on that particular day
who said rush limbaugh's right you know
you're a computer horrible human being
and i would have to chuckle because that
was you know his his fans using the
phone lines to
to make their feelings known and i think
there was
too much of a of a tendency on the part
of the mainstream media to dismiss
rush limbaugh as a kind of a
almost like a french figure but he was
anything but by the time of his death
sadly
from cancer even though a lot of the
obituaries were pretty hostile to
russian limbo which did not surprise me
there certainly was a recognition about
what a titan he was
in the broadcasting business and and
giving him his due as somebody
who really did change the course of
communication his listeners always felt
like he was one of us
like he he somehow he was part of he was
with them they were all together in some
group
yeah look he's a guy who grew up in
missouri knocked around the business he
was a publicist for the kansas city
royals so he really was a kind of a
self-made person
uh you also have to remember that rush
told me and he
said in numerous interviews that he was
an entertainer first and a conservative
second a lot of you know after russia's
success there was air america and other
liberal attempts mario cuomo had a show
one point
to try to have left wingers compete on
radio they couldn't do it mostly they
couldn't do it because they were boring
so rush was funny i mean if you know he
went after you or
people of your community you thought he
was perhaps unfair and harsh but
he had a way of keeping people listening
that always struck me and i think that's
because he understood
that if you you had to get people in the
tent if you were to kind of preach the
gospel to them
howie kurtz host of media buzz on the
fox news channel media buzz meter
podcast
thank you very much for joining us great
to talk to you
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up the biden white house is
facing
daily questions and mounting pressure
over what it calls a challenge
on the southern border we have a large
number of kids
unaccompanied children who are coming
across the border
white house spokeswoman jensaki refers
questions about the actual number of
migrants to homeland security
but a senior dhs official tells fox news
the number of migrant children in
custody
has tripled over the past two weeks to
more than three thousand
with over one thousand held at detention
facilities along the border
for longer than they're supposed to be
which is no more than three days
we are continuing to work to convey to
people in the region
that this is not the time to come that
the majority of people who come to the
border
will be turned away which is factually
accurate for the children saki says the
goal is to move them out of border
patrol facilities as quickly as possible
but she concedes right now they don't
have enough
facilities for the amount of children
crossing the border president biden
recently sent a team of senior advisors
to the region
but so far the white house continues to
assess the situation
while working to build from what it
considers a dismantled immigration
policy
meantime customs and border patrol tells
fox news some tactical checkpoints in
arizona
have been closed temporarily so manpower
can be redirected there is a crisis
on the texas border right now texas
governor greg abbott visiting the border
city of mission on tuesday
and accusing president biden of open
border policies
it invites illegal immigration and is
creating
a humanitarian crisis in texas right now
that will grow increasingly worse by the
day
abbott says cartels exploit the
situation by trying to overwhelm border
patrol officials
and he's deploying troopers and national
guard troops to assist
but he says more ice detention
facilities immigration and customs
enforcement
are needed immediately i am on the
border literally
every single week and you know this
abiding
border crisis is worse than people
realize
texas republican congressman tony
gonzalez serves a district
that includes over 800 miles of border
territory
he recently had a ride along with border
patrol met with local officials
and paid a visit to a facility
criticized during the trump
administration
but now reopened under president biden
you know i was just
at the carrico springs facility for
unaccompanied minors
and what i saw was just busting at the
seams
i mean the numbers that are coming uh
through unaccompanied minors
is through the roof and i also was able
to meet with border patrol agents
and you know they're resilient they're
dedicated
to this to ensuring that our borders are
secure
but we also got to remember that they're
regular people
just like everyone else their fathers
their mothers
and they for them to see and have to
deal with all these unaccompanied minors
it takes a toll on them as well so it is
100 a crisis that is spinning out of
control
and we need more visibility on it now
the
biden administration calls the trump
administration's approach
especially when it comes to the kids
inhumane
um but you know i guess the difference
is as you're pointing out
the numbers and the current
administration calls it a challenge not
a crisis but they are admitting that
they don't have
the capacity to handle the numbers right
now
um they're holding some of the kids
longer than 72 hours
um because they don't have the
facilities to
to send them to what would your message
to
this administration be i mean if they
consider the previous policies immoral
and humane
obviously they're not going to reinstate
them now that they've
revoked them yeah the biden
administration has been adamant on doing
one thing
reversing all of trump's policies that's
not a plan
you know and at the same breath they
were pushing this open border rhetoric
what did you think was going to happen
and and then
they go as far as being absent from the
scene
like they just want to they just want
the problem to go away
while they started a lot of these issues
what to do is they got to go back to
some of
the trump policies that worked that's
one they got to give resources
to the people that are doing the work
you know border patrol agents
sheriffs uh police officers and we have
to start enforcing our laws
and then we got to start talking about
legal immigration
and not have this open borders amnesty
discussion
that it just encourages the rhetoric
but at first they have to show up we
need the bite administration
to show up my message to them is work
with those
that are on the ground every single day
like myself
like henry cuellar like vicente gonzalez
us that are on the border that see it
every single day there's a big
difference between the way
the administration is describing even
that facility that you saw the carrizo
springs facility
and the way democrats were calling it
kids in cages when president trump was
in office
on the ground is there a difference
were you able to get inside and see it
i i was able to get inside and see it
and and the reason why i wanted to do it
for
a couple reasons is one it's critical to
understanding
uh what is happening on the border
that's one two is to really be able to
see
what kind of conditions these children
were in and so this facility is an old
uh man camp and a man camp is basically
an oil and gas
area where they build out these uh
hardened
structures and it reminded me a lot of
like military
dorms if you will and i was actually i
was able to speak with some of the
migrants
as well you know kind of just to ask
about their
their interaction they all were first
from central america honduras
el salvador guatemala and that was key
there
but you know they had abilities to to
worship they have abilities
to you know facilities for for learning
and education
all those type of things but here's the
deal this facility
does not want to house these people
beyond you know the time that they're
allowed uh
like they don't want to have that you
know if they they want
they want the border to kind of calm
down
and that starts by leadership from the
biden administration
to calm some of the open border rhetoric
down
the administration says they're telling
people not to come
right now is that a message that's not
getting through had any of the
um you know recently arrived migrants
that you spoke with
heard that that they're telling people
not to come
you know when you spend the campaign
kind of pushing this open borders
rhetoric
you know governing is a lot different
than campaigning and that's what they're
seeing they're seeing
they're having to govern this problem
set that has been around honestly a very
long time
so part of that is their actions need to
echo
like actions speak louder than words one
of the things that i'll be very specific
i'll talk about policy
here for a second so one of the things
that the bite administration did
is they did away with the pacer program
and the pacer program
allowed judges to make determinations
immediately on the border whether you
know people
were deemed you know uh whether they
fell under this
this uh a fear or not right
and that was one avenue in which you
could immediately
return migrants that did not qualify for
asylum
well the administration did away with
that so guess what of course the numbers
are going to go through the roof so
that's one of the areas they could
immediately take place
bring back the pacer program and this is
not just me saying this
this is people on the ground that are
seeing it every day
the border patrol agents cbp they're
saying this pacer program worked
but is there concern too on the other
side of that argument that
you know people who are coming from
countries that have hardships
gang violence food shortages which can
be you know weather related or pandemic
related
um driving them just out of desperation
to seek a better life
maybe they don't meet that fear index
under the pacer program you know
there was concern i guess that maybe
they would slip through the cracks
and be sent back even if they did have a
good hardship case
to plead to a judge i mean you know
is there something our government should
be doing to help assist countries like
honduras for instance
to try to stem the flow i know there
have been
uh campaigns and multiple
administrations to do that on some level
is it just not effective you know the
long-term solution
is is improving our legal immigration
system like that process is broken and i
think one way
that you could start is it you know
increasing the number of work visas
we absolutely need to know who's coming
into our country but if folks want to
come here for a better life
to fill jobs that are otherwise going
unfilled then i think there's there's an
avenue to do that
but that's not what the administration
is doing that one they're not working
with anybody
they're not talking to anybody
republicans democrats
they just have this approach of we're
going to do everything
opposite of what the trump
administration did and guess what
that has led us to the crisis that we're
in today
yeah i mean white house spokesman jen
saki keeps describing it as a
policy decision to let especially the
unaccompanied minors
come in um really basically making a
compassionate
argument there but that doesn't
change the fact that when you've got
much bigger numbers coming
in you've you've got an issue which
they're still not calling
a crisis but
where do you see this this heading i
mean is this destined to be just a
campaign issue in the 2022 midterms or
is there something
that the administration can be doing to
work with congress is it
is it almost too late to try to turn
this current problem of a big surge at
the border around
so this is this is what i'm seeing on
the border is you have communities
and remember you know immigration isn't
a new issue
right so you have folks that have grown
up with this
they've been around their their entire
lives in this in some form or fashion
those communities that reside on the
border like eagle pass
like del rio like presidio like el paso
right
so this isn't anything new so they're
compassionate they want to be able to
help
people that are coming over here for
some of the reasons that you mentioned
earlier
but what has happened is the numbers are
so
uh large so drastic that they're unable
to help
they're unable to to handle the numbers
in which
are happening so what you're seeing is
you're seeing these failed
cities if you will because of the sheer
volume
of folks coming over and it's it's just
the wrong thing to do
all around and the administration has to
step up
the administration has to one not put
their head in the sand
like they have to they have to
understand this isn't a challenge
it is a crisis and that's great that the
administration finally
sent some people out there but the
president should be
out there the vice president should be
out there seeing it
firsthand having the discussion
firsthand implementing
some of these laws and coming up with
solutions
not just saying everything is okay
texas republican congressman tony
gonzalez thank you so much for your time
we appreciate it
yeah i know thank you again for having
me on
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day
with some of the biggest newsmakers and
guests listen live on the fox news app
or get the free podcast
at guybensonshow.com review the fox news
rundown on apple podcasts or wherever
you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind a pew research study
came out this week with encouraging news
the percentage of americans who plan to
get a coveted vaccine
has gone up in the last few months from
60 percent to almost 70 percent today
there is one group however that
continues to refuse the vaccine
republican evangelicals evangelicals
were also reportedly the least likely to
say that the health of others
was an important consideration in their
decision
some commentators have warned that
evangelicals refusal
to get the vaccine could possibly
prevent the country
from reaching herd immunity prolonging
the course of the pandemic
as an evangelical pastor i find these
trends to be disturbing
evangelical christians should be lining
up to get the vaccine
not crossing their arms and refusing it
too many christians have set up a false
dichotomy between
faith and science there is no conflict
between god and true science
in fact it was the christian worldview
that led to some of the most important
breakthroughs
in science and technology isaac newton
francis bacon louis pasteur and blaise
pascal
were all people of faith who believed in
the orderly universe made by god
the creator the orderliness of nature
makes it possible to study and
understand the world
a chaotic or random universe would not
have allowed for a reliable vaccine
this is why i've been calling the
vaccines a miracle from god
god is the one who holds the universe
together at each and every moment
god's common grace made it possible for
human minds to devise
life-saving medical treatments like
vaccines
it's distressing to me that republican
evangelicals
are far and away the most distrustful of
the vaccines
this shows that politics is shaping
faith
instead of faith shaping our politics
too many people seem to be using this
twisted logic
republicans don't get vaccines i'm a
republican
so i won't get a vaccine this is the
height of silliness
a political loyalty should not override
good sense and christian love at the end
of the day
refusal to consider the vaccines reveals
a chronically
individualistic outlook on life for too
many
evangelical christians rugged
individualism
may be a classic american ideal but it
has
little to do with the christian gospel
in the new testament the apostle paul
commands christians
do not merely look out for your own
interest
but for the interest of others have the
same attitude in you
that was in christ jesus one of the
basic premises of christianity
is that life is not just about me it's
about
us we should evaluate every decision
including whether to take the vaccine by
how it might affect those around us
to my fellow evangelicals answer these
questions
honestly are you refusing the vaccine
for a serious reason
because of your conscience or are you
playing politics and flirting with
conspiracy theories
i would ask you to reconsider your
position not just for yourself
but for the sake of those around you i'm
urging the 14 000 members of our church
to be vaccinated as soon as possible and
i hope many others will follow suit
the health of our churches and our
nation
may depend upon it this is robert
jeffress
for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows
live swipe right for the latest fox news
radio newscasts on demand fox news radio
and the fox news app download it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes